JENNIFER THOMAS: Have you
heard the phrase, change
is the only constant in life?
While that may be
accurate for most things,
you don't want it to be true
for your infrastructure.
Let's take a look at how Critter
Junction learned the hard way
about adopting immutable
infrastructure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Mutable means capable of change.
In this case, we're
talking about the idea
of cloud resources that are made
to never have manual changes.
For our friends at
Critter Junction,
they started with
virtual machines
that hosted their web servers.
Their VMs were
originally designed
to be mutable because of
the short-term flexibility
it gave them.
Each VM could more precisely
fit the apps that ran on it,
and it was easy to run custom
updates for each machine.
The team often became attached
to individual machines, which
was occasionally useful
if they needed to fix
specific problems quickly.
For example, they
ran a VM with NGINX
in version 1 of
their web server,
with data written locally.
When they wanted to switch to
Apache, it was easy for them
to perform an
upgrade on the server
directly and run version 2.
On the surface,
this seems great.
They were using
an existing server
and didn't have to worry
about moving the data around
to other machines or
creating a new machine.
But in the real world,
things can go wrong.
The Apache upgrade could have
failed for a number of reasons,
like networking issues.
In their case,
some of the servers
updated quickly, while others
got hung up on installations.
They were left with some servers
running version 2 successfully,
some that upgraded the
app but couldn't run it,
and some servers that were
still running version 1.
Many of their VMs were failing
in slightly different ways.
And they were now
facing complexity
with user traffic being
routed to different running
versions of their web
server, an inability
to roll back to a
previous version,
and undocumented
update statuses,
making it impossible
to track versions.
Instead of changing each
of their existing VMs,
they should have changed their
environment to be immutable.
Once a VM is deployed,
it can't be modified.
No updates, no patches,
no configuration changes.
If you want to change
application code
or apply a patch, you instead
would build a new image
and deploy it as a replacement.
Because new environments
can be spawned
in the cloud in a
matter of minutes,
immutable infrastructure is
easy to architect and deploy.
After some long hours restoring
version 1 of their application,
here's how Critter Junction
handled their next deployment.
Instead of making changes
in place to each machine,
they created a brand
new VM image with Apache
and version 2 of their app, and
moved any locally written data
to an attached persistent disk.
After some testing to make
sure the new image was working,
they spun up multiple
servers using the new image.
Now they could safely switch
traffic to their new VMs
and shut down the instances
running version 1.
On Google Cloud, it looked
like this for their team.
They used Cloud Build to set
up continuous integration
with their repository,
automating billing and testing.
VMs were specified
using image families
so they could have multiple
versions of their images
and deprecate the
newest versions if they
needed to roll back.
And they specified all
of their resources using
Cloud Deployment
Manager in order
to automatically provision it.
This is the same pattern as
working with containers--
create a complete
runtime environment
and deliver that as an image.
With containers, the
runtime environment
is a program and the
files it needs to run.
With immutable
infrastructure, you're
delivering a whole operating
system, configured as needed,
along with the programs
and their files.
In both cases, you continuously
deliver versioned images.
Creating immutable
infrastructure
gave Critter Junction protection
from configuration drift,
since they now know the
exact state of their machines
and can avoid any
unexpected surprises.
In addition, they can now
easily track versions, roll back
releases, and have a more
consistent testing process,
thanks to the
documented differences
between their environments.
Immutable infrastructure
might sound at odds
with agile architecture.
But in reality, it
gives you agility
because you know the
specifics and code
status for every resource
in your environment.
Stay tuned to find out what's
in store for Critter Junction.
And remember-- always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]